I come to this video zigma Tom's like
Marta from Turkey and I'm staying with
this kind of g6 stock let's do do a
modern defense here with a five right
now can be boring and trade on e5 but
it's not it's not a big problem ok here
maybe takes and then here from 96 looks
like it loses some time for white yeah
he can play something like f 3 m-f 396
Bishop to e3 and is ok or P should be to
something like that still looks like a
decent Kings Indian type of position
where Bishop takes you four is something
that is not not good all the time ok
quick rook e8 coming
this also knight c6 Bishop b3 94
sometimes but Bishop g5 after that I
already don't see a big point to that ok
go here and be sure g4 should be should
be fine okie dokie let's take here wow
what I'm going to Castle long here that
looks like that looks like a very
ambitious way to play ok maybe he can do
that okay maybe just set it up for b5 if
he castles long that I can do b5 to open
up the position cooking
one way to defend him it's always night
to h5 at the right moment ok so I'm
going to play 95 hun if you have be five
in the mix if he goes F for 97 years we
can be four so I have rupee 895 things
it's interesting I mean I I really did
not think that G take some f is any good
but it's not that clear it really isn't
one problem of this knight on c6 is that
it makes it difficult to play c6 yeah
see 65c 6b five those counter-attack
this is why this regrouping it's not
that that bad actually I want this rook
on yet and maybe 95 if he goes long
castles I will play b5 of course wait I
it's the good it's good I was a little
bit afraid that maybe c5 is a move but
that I have before important so that I
get a 40 k takes yeah and now let's see
how to play that there are there's more
than one way to do it I can play
something like we'd be eight or I can do
something drastic immediately like
Knight takes e4 yeah Knight takes e4
night 64 group takes a tool but that's
not so convincing I I guess I should
involve the Queen him
it's really about opening lines not
about material if I if it's impossible
move but I thought that I just thought
that said it's not possible but probably
it is it probably is chicks be 57
thought about this a little bit longer
that's never ever objectively correct
yeah what's up late yet absolutely never
now of course i have to now we can even
take the rook probably if i take on f4 i
think that really was good at the
beginning of it but if you play it that
badly it's not going to work
let's let's do it like that trying to
hope that I can do something with the
night I'm a told I'm a rope down i know
but i thought that maybe there are more
chances for a swindle when there is a
night on the board okay 64 b6
I don't even see any of any tricks iam
the only thing that is always left is
this long diagonal yeah where were you
in the Kings Indian you sometimes have
the weirdest possibilities for swindles
yeah dropping back he took a long time
she worried about something he i don't i
don't really see any kind of play for me
him to be honest not even the night i
can can be can be easily activated maybe
nite nite year night d 64 something hit
me queen bee three rupee six I mean this
is really playing even slower than I am
okay let's let's take a look T 196 Queen
time morning before or something
it's still really no threat whatsoever
um yeah if I give chick here Queen a
true check one Queen a Jew anyway i can
if i give this cheeky also check its
kind of unnerving here so i can check
here we can check some material at least
now if i take on a to what is this is a
pawn for a couple of I mean a pin apiece
for a couple of poles and I am active
that's not not that clear actually now
it is of course it's still bad but now
check I have no idea what this is this
kind of position to call this is quite
substantial but he's quick enough for
his cooking oh my time oops check check
Jack for fits on time what did i do here
ah I'm terribly terribly impractical
sometimes yeah I mean I'm on the clock
for seconds and the position is is
totally ok yeah I'm even winning at the
computer gives us there's a winner with
f4 and set of g3 had even this wins but
I did I have no time now I got in the
shock hit me and I played kings you for
f4 just wins iam
and I'm and I'm promoting but losing on
time okay I mean okay the position i
don't know what i wrote down yeah so but
but actually losing on time at the end
this is like totally unnecessary right
okay let's have a look at this so be
five it was probably not a good idea now
that we look at this especially hoping
if I've was really bad and here I'm
really just just material down for for
nothing you just have this kind of hope
that there's some sort of miracle
happening but it was really just losing
on along which I well you can always
hang on and try to muddy the waters but
but losing on time how on earth is this
possible even oh my thanks for watching